t
c'est ici où ça ne bouge
toujours pas.
Reportage.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'endroit ne vaut vraiment pas
le détour. Située à côté de
la Grande bibliothèque et
du Parc Émilie Gamelin,
l'ancienne gare d'autocars de
MoMontréal offre un triste payse
aux passants et aux visiteurs.
- Ça m'attriste de voir que
c'est abandonné depuis plus
de 10 ans. Alors à chaque année,
je me dis : mon Dieu, quand
est-ce qui va se passer quelque
chose, là?
- Enmomomoment, quelques
locaux sont occuppés de façon
temporaire, notamment par
un service de livraison de colis
à vélo et par la coopérative
Les Valoristes, un pointdedede s
consignés.
L'ancien terminus est
désaffecté depuis que
la nouvelle gare d'autocars a
ouvert ses portes, en 2011,
p p peu plus au nord, dans
le même quadrilatère baptisé
l'ilôt voyageur.
Une décennie plus tard,
ceux qui arrivent en autobus
doivent toujours sortir dehorsar
rejoindre l'entrée du métro.
Il n'y a toujours pas
de passage intérieur.
Ils aboutissent ensuite ici,
un autre endroit qui ne risque
pas de les éblouir
par sa beauté.
- Je trouve que ça donne
vraiment pas une belle image
de Montréal, là. Les gens
qui arrivent de l'extérieur,
ils doivent se dire : "Ayoye,
je vivrais pas à Montréal, moi."
- Démarré par l'Université
du Québec à Montréal en 2005,
le projet de l'ilôt voyageur est
devenu un gouffre financier.
Le gouvernemeébébébébébec
a dû racheter le projet
immobilier inachevé.
La partie nord a été vendue
au Groupe Aquilini en 2013,
qui y a construit 700 logements.
Et puis en 2018, la Ville
de Montréal a acheté
l'ancienne gare d'autocars
pourioioioioions de dollars.
rrrrrrrrrrait s'attendre à...
d'ici la fin du mandat,
à commencer un projet
de construction.
- Qu'il y ait des...- - - - - Q.
- Qu'il y ait des pépines là...
- Et non il n'y a toujours pas
de pépines.
L'administration Plante auéuéux
de construction avant la fin
de son premier mandat, en 2021,
pour un projet comprenant
des logements sociaux et
abordables, ainsi quebububububus
BENOIT DORAIS, resp. habitation
Comité eilililililille de Mtl
- La pandémie a vraiment fait
en sorte qu'on doit revoir
au complet tout ce qui est
l'offre de bureau. Est-ce que ça
tient toujours?
- Alors que la Ville a adopté
une politique de télétravail
et que les tours à bureaux
se vident dans la métropole,
l'administration Plante
a décidé de retourner
à la planche à dessin.
- Là, on doit rebrasser
les caururururururura assurément
du résidentiel, mais quels
seront les pourcentages
en communautaire? Probablement,
logement étudiant, il y a
quelque chose comme ça...
Donc, on doit prendre le temps
d'y arriver, mais dans un futur
proche, on va y arriver.
- Ça a un très grand potentiel
de développement, puis
malheureusement, bien dans
un site aussi névralgique
au centre de la Ville, bienon v,
il n'a rien qui est fait.
- L'opposition, à l'hôtel
de Ville, est d'accord avec
le développement de logements
sociaux et étudiants sur
le site de l'ancienne gare.
Mais elle déplore les délais
qui s'accumulent.
En septembre dernier, elle a
poussé le conseil municipal
à adopter une motion pour
qu'un plan d'aménagement
soit présenté d'ici la fin
de l'année prochaine.
JULIEN HÉNAULT-RATELLE, p.-p.
opp. off. dév. économique, Mtl
- Là, ça fait cinq ans que ça a
été acquis par la Ville. Il y a.
Il y a eu le PPU du quartier
latin. Il y a eu le PPU
des faubourgs. Il y a eu
des consultations avec
la table de quartier.
- Et il reste aussi la portion
nord-est de l'Îlot Voyageur
à développer, en bordure
de la rue St-Hubert.
Le Groupe Aquilini, qui en est
le propriétaire, n'y a pas
encore construit de logements
comme il l'a fait du côté
de la rue Berri.
Aux dernières nouvelles, il y
avait mésentente avec la Ville,
qui souhaitait que le projets
inclue des logements familiaux.
Lors ,,,,,,,,,
des employés de l'entreprise
sécurisaient les serrures
sur les portes des locaux
vacants, au rez-de-chaussée,
pour éviter que des personnes
llllllllllllllllllent s'y
réfugier.
Pour Danielle BrochuÎlot Voyag.
- Avoir une place publique
avec beaucoup de verdure,
du verdissement, il pourrait
même à l'occasion avoir
des petits marchés, comme au...
à d'autres stations de métro.
- Mais pour ça, il faudra
attendre encore quelques années
au moins.
♪ ♪